you know boba fett as an original star
wars trilogy villain but did you know he
could actually get worse from planting
bombs to almost killing a baby these are
the worst things boba fett has ever done
in his first canonical appearance after
attack of the clones boba fett pursued a
quest of vengeance against mace windu
the jedi responsible for beheading his
father jango fett this plot unfolded in
the second season of star wars the clone
wars during the episode death trap in
the episode a young fett takes on the
identity of a clone trooper named lucky
with this disguise he's able to
infiltrate mace windu's quarters and
place a motion-activated bomb in his
room all in the hopes of murdering the
jedi and finally getting revenge for his
dad while fett is successful in both
planting and setting off the bomb it
doesn't end up killing his intended
target an innocent clone trooper is
instead slaughtered after inadvertently
setting the bomb off but in the wake of
this unintentional killing fett doesn't
give up on his plans for vengeance
though he's initially reluctant he
decides to attack the reactor core of a
republic star destroyer if it works it's
a plan that wouldn't just kill windu but
also everyone else on board through his
bombing plan and subsequent unsuccessful
attack on the reactor core it's clear
that fett is seriously grappling with
the loss of his father by inflicting
more pain on others and it's also
apparent that he's more than willing to
kill anyone who gets in the way of his
target he may still be a kid but fett's
already brutal beyond his years a few
seasons after his first appearance in
the clone wars fett returned a little
older but still just as dangerous in
season four's bounty bet had become an
even more hardened soul thanks to an
extended prison sentence no longer just
seeking revenge for his father that was
inching closer to his portrayal in the
empire strikes back by making a living
as a bounty hunter to pursue this goal
fett partnered with a squad of fellow
hunters got a mask to conceal his
identity and took a job delivering a
large chest to the powerful ruler otua
blanc while on his delivery mission it
was revealed that the chest didn't
contain jewels or weapons but instead
held a young woman named pluma sodi who
was being sent to blank as a forced
bride when darkseid force user asajj
ventress who'd briefly joined fett's
crew for this assignment realized what
their true cargo was she hesitated but
while the former sith apprentice had a
crisis of conscience fett demonstrated
his growing darkness by remaining firmly
committed to the task at hand in fat's
previous clone wars story he seemed
uncertain about hurting innocent people
but this time pluma sodi's suffering
fell on deaf ears that's ruthlessness
sometimes manifests in shooting
adversaries and other times it emerges
in ignoring the cries of the helpless
while it may seem like the empire
strikes back was the first instance of
boba fett and darth vader crossing paths
media outside of the movies has made it
apparent that the two characters met
before one such encounter came in
marvel's 2015 star wars comic series
which saw boba fett being hired by darth
vader to track down a figure who'd
worked alongside obi-wan kenobi during
the events of a new hope now on the hunt
for his bounty fett was willing to
achieve his goal by any means necessary
including murder while trying to track
down his target fett encountered a
number of people including rodians and a
group of moisture farmers that he
interrogated for information once they
told him what he needed to know they
weren't released back to their humdrum
lives but instead were promptly killed
by phet this approach even extended to
an unnamed farmer at the moss icely
cantina who after being viciously
interrogated dropped a bombshell
revelation to fete that the man he was
looking for was named luke skywalker in
one of his earliest missions for darth
vader that was on a hot pursuit that
left a long trail of corpses behind
while many were introduced to boba fett
through the empire strikes back it
wasn't the first appearance of the
character that actually made his debut
in one of the most infamous pieces of
star wars media the star wars holiday
special in between scenes featuring
harvey korman as a cooking show host and
the arthur cronin there was an animated
segment entitled the story of the
faithful wookie in this short story boba
fett arrives as a newly introduced
character riding a dinosaur-esque
creature he seems to want to help luke
skywalker and friends on their mission
to retrieve a mystical object that
serves as the plot's macguffin though
fett initially acts as a helpful figure
it's later revealed that he's no ally
r2d2 ends up discovering that fett is
communicating with darth vader so that
he can reveal the location of the rebels
to the villain eventually r2
communicates this news to the rest of
the crew which prompts anger from han
solo and forces boba fett to scurry away
but not before vowing vengeance on the
team the animated adventure doesn't show
us boba fett at his most grisly but it
does show him as a duplicitous
self-serving being right from the start
in the empire strikes back darth vader
is a man on a mission he's been chasing
after luke skywalker and company for
quite a while but the good guys keep
dodging him so the villain decides to
hire a little extra help sending out a
call for a crew of bounty hunters among
those answering the call are ruffians
like dengar bosk and of course boba fett
in his first live action appearance he
isn't even on screen for a full minute
before vader turns to phet and orders
him to refrain from disintegrating his
quarry fett lives up to this reputation
throughout the rest of the movie as he
slickly tracks an unwitting han solo
through space the bounty hunter doesn't
even blink at his mission here his only
moment of real hesitation comes when he
thinks solo might be killed in the
carbonite freezing process this isn't
because he's worried the process is too
cruel instead his only concern is how
it'll impact his finances since jabba
the hutt would like solo to arrive alive
fett's inclination to put money over
people and his ability to keep a cool
head are both exemplified throughout his
mission in the empire strikes back
everyone loves grogu that little guy
formerly known to fans as baby yoda has
quickly become one of the most beloved
star wars characters of all time
stop touching things
in the process of spawning memes all
over the internet he's also helped put
the mandalorian on the map and only 14
episodes into the show's run audiences
have become totally captivated by grogo
which made him the perfect target to
emphasize the cold-hearted nature of
boba fett when fett first meets dinjarin
the lead character of the mandalorian
he's not there purely to shed more blood
that having emerged from the sarlacc pit
wants to get his mandalorian armor back
i don't want your armor
i want my armor to instill some leverage
into the scenario fett remarks that he's
got an ally fennec shand poised with a
sniper rifle nearby while jaron notes
that his armor would protect him from
any sniper blast that clarifies that
jaren wouldn't be shan's target instead
at fett's signal the sniper would shoot
and kill grosgu who's busy meditating so
that he can call out for any other jedi
in the galaxy by the time this episode
aired boba fett had existed in pop
culture for over four decades and his
ruthless reputation was well known but
by threatening to kill a beloved
character like grogu fett's cold-hearted
nature was taken to a whole other level
and established for a whole new
generation of star wars fans
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
star wars are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you